is there a case to be made that even for
like communication between you and i
we should move away from uh from email
like for example there's a guy i
recently i don't know if you know
comedians but there's a guy named joey
diaz
yeah that i've had an interaction with
recently and that guy
first of all the sweetest human despite
what his comedy
sounds like he's the sweetest human
being and he's a big proponent of just
pick up
the phone yeah and call yeah and it
makes me so uncomfortable
people call me yeah it's like i don't
know what to do with this thing
uh but it kind of gets everything done
quicker i think
if i remove the anxiety from that is
there a case to be made for that or this
email
could still be the most efficient way to
do this no i mean look if you if you
have to interact with someone
there's a lot of efficiency in synchrony
right and this is something from
distributed system theory where you know
if you go from synchronous to
asynchronous networks
there's a huge amount of overhead to the
asynchrony so actually the protocols
required to solve things
in asynchronous networks are
significantly more complicated and
fragile than
synchronous protocols so if we can just
do real time it's usually better and
also from a
interaction like social connection
standpoint there's a lot more
information in the human voice and the
back and forth
uh yeah if you just call so very
generational right
like our generation will be comfortable
talking on the phone in a way that like
a younger generation isn't but an older
generation is more comfortable with well
you just call people whereas we so
there's a happy medium but most of my
good friends
we just talk we have regular phone calls
okay yeah
it's not i don't just call them we
schedule it we schedule it yeah just on
text like yeah you want to talk
sometime soon do you do you ever have a
processes around friends
not really no i feel like i should i
feel like uh well you have like a lot of
interesting
friend possibilities you have like an
interesting problem right like really
interesting people
you can talk to well that's that's one
problem the other one is the
introversion
where i'm just afraid of people and get
really stressed like
i freak out and so you picked a good
line of work
yeah now perhaps it's the goggins thing
it's like facing your fears or whatever
but but it's almost like
there's uh it has to do with the
timetables thing and the deep work
that the nice thing about the processes
is
it not only uh automates sort of uh
automates away the contact switching it
ensures you do
the important things too like yeah it's
like prioritize so
the thing is with email because
everything is done over email
you can be lazy in the same way with
like social networks and and do the easy
things first
that are not that important so the
process also
enforces that you do the important
things and for me the important
things is like okay it sounds weird but
like social connection
no that's one of the most important
things in all of human existence
yeah and doing it the the paradoxical
thing
i got into this for digital minimalism
uh the more you sacrifice on behalf of
the connection the stronger the
connection feels
right so sacrificing non-trivial time
and attention on behalf of someone is
what tells your brain that this is a
a serious relationship which is why
social media had this paradoxical effect
making people feel less social because
it took the friction out of it
and so the brain just doesn't like yeah
you've been commenting on this person's
whatever you've been retweeting them or
sending them some text you haven't it's
not hard enough
and then then the the perceived strength
of that social connection diminishes
where if you talk to them or go spend
time with them or whatever
you're going to feel better about it so
the friction is good
i have a thing with some of my friends
where at the end of each call we take a
couple minutes to schedule the next
then you never it's like i do with
haircuts or something right like if i
don't schedule it then
yeah i'm never going to get my hair cut
right and so we it's like okay
when you want to talk next you know yeah
that's a really that's a really good
idea
i i just don't call friends and uh like
every 10 years i do something dramatic
for them so then we maintain the
friendship like
i'd murder somebody that they really
don't like i just careful
joey might ask you just yet that's why
it's one of my favorites you gotta come
down to new jersey that's exactly what
we're gonna do
that robot dog of yours
[Music]
you